as it stands there isn't much love out
there for the resurrection of a park and
if you're a fan that's new to this
series you might feel inclined to skip
this arc entirely given how badly people
criticize it and while I would advise
skipping this wretch of a display I have
to give credit where credit is due and
this arc deserves infinitely more praise
than its given so while a large chunk of
the main fight is well garbage this arc
has much more to offer than you might
think
action slapstick and of course at times
superb animation now before I begin I
would like to extend a huge thank you to
at anime AJ on Twitter this man has put
together a terrific animation archive
for Dragon Ball super on the Kai's n
shoe forums without his continued hard
work these videos would be much more
difficult to make I'll leave the links
to his archive as well as his Twitter
and YouTube accounts in the description
down below now let's get this show on
the road I'm totally not Marc and these
are the 10 best animated moments of
Dragon Ball super resurrection of F Park
number 10
old-school art style right off the heels
the battle of gods arc Toei animation
decided to bring shuichi he Seki a
freelance animator into the fold he had
provided some brief key animations and
in-between work for shows like kill a
kill and even yelling but really this
guy by and large was an unknown who had
primarily worked the animated music
videos online but that didn't stop a sec
you from showing us what we hadn't seen
it over a decade classic Dragon Ball Z
style artwork many people feel that the
art direction for Dragon Ball super is
too rounded and soft looking skinnier
bodies rounded cheeks curved shading
smooth noses and rounded ears these are
all intentional design choices that
today Yoshi
Yama Moro has made as the lead character
designer for the series he has been
known to be very strict with his
character designs which has helped him
garner a reputation for being a little
full of himself and overbearing on the
animators that work underneath him but
seemingly out of nowhere
Shuichi isakki gave us this episode
pointed ears angular facial features and
sharp shading came back for one last
hurrah this scene in particular was
clearly a tribute to a scene from the
Android saga of Dragon Ball Z you really
can see the similarities here today he
has only done one episode of Dragon Ball
super but I pray he does more in the
future he is a talented artist and
although his stint was
he created a nostalgic moment out of
what could have been just another
episode number nine freezes regeneration
Yukihiro katana you might know this man
as the animator who supervised episode 1
what you might not know is that he also
was the animation supervisor behind this
episode which features some of the worst
of the series this however is in no
small part due to the insane schedule
that Dragon Ball super has to follow
thankfully episode 19 had plenty of time
to be produced and is without a doubt
one of the best-looking and consistent
episodes of the entire arc featuring
this little nugget for freezes
regeneration pulsating flesh and torn
limbs all extend and heal seamlessly
some great lighting and unmodeled
artwork too it's a very atmospheric
scene that's fitting for an old favorite
to return number 8 summoning the eternal
dragon dragon ball always animates their
dragons really well who just suddenly
got really cold
who anyway taken straight from episode
19 again this features quite a nice
entrance for Shenron arms and face
extending out of the beams of life
whiskers waving and hair blowing in the
air it's always a treat when we see the
eternal dragon wood Oh God seriously
sabaki cold
k'tano and the rest of the key animators
did tremendously with the last two spots
as an animator who has a reputation for
being inconsistent we're under pressure
he seems to be consistently showing up
on this list number 7 Dragon Ball super
intro sequence now this is some truly
spectacular animation animated by the
exceedingly talented Ryo Onishi the only
reason this hasn't ranked higher is its
length this while amazing is two seconds
long usually I would refrain from
including these intro sequences but this
was so good I had to include it the use
of composition camera positioning and
close-up all pulled together with
expressive facial features an excellent
job by Ryo Onishi number 6
Goku gets kicked this right here is my
favorite episode of the entire arc and
this is exactly what I wanted more of in
the movie the interactions between
Vegeta and Goku in this episode are a
joy to watch and provide some of the
biggest lash of the entire series in
this scene we find
Goku and Vegeta trying to change lord
beerus as bed sheets while he sleeps
hijinks ensues as the two tried to get
their work done without waking the
sleeping God however when he least
expects it
Goku finds himself on the receiving end
of beerus his tail swipe flying towards
one of the floating alarm clock bombs
the cheetah ops to kick Goku into the
wall to prevent the explosion which
almost certainly would have woken the
sleeping deity its reasons like this I
love being a Dragon Ball fan these
unique character interactions help make
times of peace both fun and interesting
this episode was supervised by none
other than the insanely talented Naoki
Tata his style unmistakable he really
tries to make this episode stand out in
an enjoyable and visually stimulating
way great facial expressions and some
nice action combined with great comedy
if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend it number five the Z warriors
vs. the freeze of force at this point we
should consider Tatsuya
ouka and shusui Munnabhai as an
animation duo they have found themselves
working on ghost in the shell and full
metal alchemist in the past but of late
they have been assigned to important
episodes of Dragon Ball super episode 21
saw these two focus on some great
intricate combat animation for the Z
fighters as they systematically take out
the freezer force some nice movement
mixed with interesting colors and
explosions brought this scene to life
for me
notice how piccolo blocks this punch his
hand buckles from the weight of his
opponent right hook motion door carries
Piccolo's responding pan strike to shin
of his opponent causing his neck to push
back and extend I love that kind of
attention to detail and this section of
the episode looked just spectacular
some more of this please number 4 Goku
vs Frieza old power believe it or not
the very same episode that produced this
also brought us this heated exchange the
very first time we see golden Frieza and
Super Saiyan blue Goku come to blows
it's a sight to behold animation that
looks like it's plucked straight from
the movie you feel the intensity as we
the audience are brought in close to the
action to feel the magnitude of the
fight the job of the animation
supervisor is to ensure that his or her
episode has consistent animation
throughout and normally there's only one
animation supervisor fulfilling this
role
however because of supers insane
schedule Joey has been putting as many
as four
supervisors to a given episode to ensure
it reaches its deadline this is a clear
sign of a show that's struggling to
complete an episode it's not the
animation supervisors fault here again
Tory has some incredibly talented people
working for them producing a weekly
animated TV show is just incredibly hard
so while this episode had its bad
moments let's not forget to appreciate
this gem that was produced amidst the
chaos number three Goku and Vegeta
sparring back at arrow with episode 19
again this time we find ourselves in the
middle of a training exercise with goku
vegeta and Wiese beginning with a
gorgeous charge of Vegeta towards the
camera every frame of this could be
somos desktop wallpaper it continues
featuring some nice combat over even
better water animation Goku rejoins the
fray as we continue this superb showing
capped off with this perfectly drawn
hand for weeks this arguably could be
the best moment in the entire arc when
it pertains to animation but at this
point in the countdown competition is
stiff Gaetano supervise this episode and
produce something truly special however
his last episode before this one was
episode 7 that means he had well over 10
weeks to complete this one when under
pressure for time he has struggled to
keep quality up take episode 24 for
example he had half the time to produce
that episode and as a result things just
fell apart it just goes to show that
even the best animators can struggle
when they are put under enough pressure
I hope that people can leave this video
knowing that the animators are towing
our talented it should be juice some
amazing stuff thankfully katana was
given enough time to produce this for us
as a result it looks sensational number
2 Naoki [ __ ] Tata this is a man who
knows how to work within the ridiculous
parameters of Dragon Ball super schedule
where some would settle for stiff simple
motions for the sake of a model accuracy
Naoki Tata decides to take it in the
opposite direction sacrificing model
accuracy to ensure that the audience at
home doesn't just watch this all day he
keeps his drawings loose and full of
energy
long exaggerated strikes give greater
weight and power to each punch delivered
he plays with the consistency of Anatomy
to give the blow greater weight notice
how he draws the hand perfectly but as
it moves quickly across the screen it
becomes a streak of color before we
gaining structure upon impact this gives
us drawings more power whether it's the
imaginative fight sequences great facial
expressions or his use of shaky limbs to
create a struggle that looks very
convincing Naoki tatay managed to pull
some great stuff out of the bag where
people like katana would have just
played it safe Toei animation are lucky
to have this man on their team number
one
the cheetah dismantles golden Frieza
many of you might have seen this coming
and in truth deciding my number one for
this list was much more difficult than I
thought it would be that said I feel
this scene epitomizes what this act
could have been this is the one scene
from the anime that is arguably better
than the movie from a story point of
view this is much more satisfying for
the viewer we get to see the Saiyan
Prince finally get his revenge on the
individual who eradicated his entire
family at home world perfectly on model
some very nice punches and intricate
combat great particle effects too I made
this list primarily to highlight some
truly great artwork and animation that
this arc which many pandas being a waste
of time has it's clear that hard work
was put into this series and honestly
I'm amazed that this arc was able to
produce as much quality as it did I
loved the conversations that take place
under my videos people are passionate
about this series and I can understand
the frustration that proves when things
are not going as perfectly as you
imagine it in your head so while I'll
agree this arcs main battle was
disappointing it also offered tons of
enjoyable moments that in many ways
exceeded my own expectations these guys
work extremely hard in this series and I
mean extremely hard I hope you guys
enjoyed the video and if you would like
to see more top tens like this please
feel free to subscribe this is being the
10 best animated bones of Dragon Ball
super is resurrection of f mark thank
you so much for watching